beaucoup d'animation depuis hier dans
les rues de cergy pontoise et tout
particulièrement à la préfecture de
cergy que le cinéaste henri verneuil a
transformé pour les besoins de son
dernier film en un véritable palais
gouvernemental dans le scénario du film
de verneuil la ville nouvelle à plus
d'une ressemblance avec dallas le
président d'un état imaginaire il est en
effet victime alors qu'il roule en
voiture d'un attentat un inconnu ouvrent
le feu sur lui avec un fusil à lunette
voici donc cergy pontoise à l'heure
américaine ce matin au moment des
premiers tours de manivelles de i comme
icare le titre du film de verneuil dans
lequel yves montand interprète le rôle
d'un procureur est-ce que vous vous
attendiez à voir quelqu'un d'important
cergy-pontoise texas
non
et
à
il car 40 de jeu rappelez-vous 7 et 23
le pays dans lequel se situe cette
action est un pays imaginaire
il faut donc d une architecture et il ne
ville qui soit une ville de n'importe où
ça peut être new york ça peut être paris
ça peut être
montréal ça peut poyer c'est mon club
vous tournez marché modestement comme
plus grand oui vous êtes des singes et
pourtant oui
comment comment ça s'est passé comment
vous avez été recruté
bien c'est une affaire qui serait à l'
agence de l'emploi
il a fait appel à 400 millions à
regarder on n'a pas à faire même dans
les champs je suis présenté aux attentes
et on va dire je n'ai rien à faire
santé quand vous tournez au milieu des
gens des gens de tous les jours est ce
parfum qui vous reconnaissent des choses
comme ça mais je vous dirais une bonne
chose c'est que lorsque vous êtes en
train de de l'interpréter à sa longue
être le personnage vous ne les voyez pas
rien ne vois rien je suis dans mon
personnage dans les pas bons je me suis
dit ils vont tourner en français
vous attendez la tête
ouais